this is a production of Cornell
University
stammers caused by proxy Mia Grameen is
for me especially treaties is the most
damaging disease of reeds
it's an obligate bio drove in changes
healthy-looking crop to a stem covered
with black sport in weeks prior to
harvest and it can also cause a yield
loss of up to hundred percent when is
under severe epidemics when acceptable
variety is grown and this picture is a
picture taken in Ethiopia in 2013-14 due
to an epidemic
due to an epidemic which caused hundred
percent euros on popular variety called
devalue due to an emergence of a new
race the fungus is atrocious and it has
a complex life cycle with all the five
sports states the main host is sweet and
barbaric is an alternate host this is
the life cycle of their cottaging as you
see from here infection starts with a
show spore which is sexual sport and we
to hit dispersal is through the Paseos
force which are sections sexual sports
tourist maturity the fungus is
overwintering Australia spores which
undergo scary Ogami under conducive
environment and infects the barbary plus
plant as positive spore and then it
undergoes its sexual cycle in terms to
pick new sports initial spores and
continues the cycle so stem rust is a
global problem where wheat is grown in
the world this map is showing the stable
survey in 2017 in areas with red circles
are areas with greater than 40% severity
so as you see from this map it's all
over the world in 40% severity is huge
enough to cause a damage the sport of
PDT has the ability to disperse long
distances another challenge with this
pathogen so as you see from this map the
spores are windblown spores are
traveling from their long distance as
you see from this map they are
travelling for
the thousand parts of us to the northern
part and cause a damage and this map is
showing the dispersal of ug99 from
uganda into in 1999 - Kenya - Kenya
Ethiopia Yemen in the rest part of the
world so this nature of the pathogen
code makes it's challenging for
management and the common management
options are front side spraying and
genetic resistance as we all know fan
aside spraying is costly and it's not
eco-friendly and the pathogen may
develop funny side resistance upon
continuous use so genetic resistance is
economical and eco-friendly to use and
there are two classes of genetic
resistance and its seedling resistance
origin which is rate specific and
expressed at seedling stage and adult
plant resistance which is expressed at
adult plant stage and it's more durable
than sitting resistance so we did
evaluation seedling evaluation against
for important trace and for this we have
got a panel of 200 its regional types
from from simit and we evaluated for see
during response in University of
Minnesota this military facility against
four races the ticket TT KSK is the
original ug99 raise ticket ETF is the
deagle race and they are recipient ttrt
if our special Buuren races seedlings
were planted in the university of asila
t there and inoculated with the sport
suspension seven days after planting
then scoring will was 1014 days post
inoculation based on its 0 to 4 scale of
stockman and this scaling method has
plus and minus based on the spore size
and there are some simple default here
for hypersensitive response and we
linearized that to 0 to 9 scale
according to thank to make it easy and
for analysis
so the distribution of sibling response
of the panels against the forest as you
see there are different levels of
responses from race specific to
broad-spectrum resistance as you see
from these lines for genotypes which
have less than or equal to 6 are
categorized and resistance in those
above 6 categorized under susceptible so
we are expecting adult plant resistance
from the seedlings acceptable so this is
a table showing the level of resistance
from 1 2 to 3 to a combination of races
so there is range of seedling resistance
in here so having combined resistance is
good enough to combine it with other
sorts of residences to get enough
liberals and it stands for stem burst
so we we asked the genotyping is done in
North Carolina USDA we haven't got data
yet we'll be getting it soon but we
asked them to run the markers for most
known is our genes they run for there is
our to is a certain allure 46 and when I
see none of our materials have the sr2
gene sr2 is unknown at this plant
resistance gene and it's durable and has
been affected for more than about 100
years I've seen on the literature and
it's her 13 the majority of the d'haran
genotypes we have about 70% of them have
a 13 this is our 13 gene is it's more
prevalent in remain effective to all the
certain lineage of the ug99 but this
gene is defeated by the GRC to see gene
I mean the GRC to series and L are 46 is
an adult difference another plant
residence for leaf rust and this gene is
tightly linked to the other plant stem
rust resistance gene SR 58 and this is
an indication that we may have some APR
genes or some sitting instance genes
and about 30% of the materials have bows
as you see from this graph we have high
level of resistance for the TK t TF n TT
KSK race this is because compared to the
Durham races to the GS in the ttrt FS
these two we have high level of
resistance because as I mentioned
earlier the Durham genotypes we have
here have more as our 13 in these two
press veralyn
2's are 30 this is also the correlation
between the response between their
forests as like this it's this one the
TT KS a K and the ticketed if response
is high this is because of the
resistance of the current tools it's
tourists but this are these rates are
still violent on another more frequent
gene is r9 e that's why we included them
in here and so I tried to fit linear
mixed model using le mayor function of
our considering the genotype and
replication as a random effect and
estimated heritability for single race
from point six one two point nine one
which is high enough and it makes sense
because it is very specific of quantity
for distance when I will when I feel the
combined analysis for the genotype by
race interaction to the previous model
hurt ability of about 0.5 eight five
estimated this is also pretty high and
it makes sense because this is
qualitative real resistance and we
evaluated to see a panel of these the
same genotypes for adult plant
resistance including three chicks in
randomized complete block design in
tulips in Ethiopia in Kenya and this is
how the nursery looks and their
genotypes were planted in two rows of
one meter in links and surrounded by
spray the Rose the spreader rows are a
combination of universally susceptible
varieties with equal proportion
there are four and the four suspensions
will be inoculated on the spread arose
at one meter interval and I'm scoring
his weight on severity and response
severity is based on the modified scale
method which is estimating the area of
steam covered the percentage of area of
the simple posture and response is based
on Rolf's in our stance for instance
Emily's bowler readers model clear
instance ms is morality susceptible in
aces for susceptible so sometimes there
is a combination of response and in this
case we are trying to change the two by
combining two coefficient of infection
by multiplying severity by a constant
for the response and this is the data we
are using for analysis so this is a
distribution of the same rest response
into a panel of season 2018 and it's
pretty normal and this is amazing the
main season distribution which is a bit
skewed and tried to normalize it by
square root transformation to fit linear
model and for the off season I filtered
linear mixed model using s Raymond and
the special correction and in this model
I considered the genotype effect as a
random and rapey fix or toss around I
mean included the coloman effect because
one tastes for column 50 significant in
heritability 0.71 estimator for this one
and for their main season the special
collection didn't work well and I fitted
the a linear function of R and
considering the rape in the genotype as
a random 15 heritability of 0.6 for
estimated I received this data by mail
and I have to check this again this is a
distribution of their response of the
planners in Kenya and in Kenya the
predominant race at the ug99 race SK in
the TT KS so as you see it's skewed to
the right and it's there is more
resistance to the canaries to Paris this
is because of the Durham race the SR
search engine which is resistant to the
Kenya races and I tried to terminate
normalize it to fit linear model by
square root transformation and like the
previous time I fit a linear mixed model
using a stray melt and it's partial
correction in this case both the column
and row vectors the one taste is
significant so I maintain them in the
model and estimated heritability of
about point seven seven which is so good
for filler instance so in summary a
simplest is the most destructive disease
of width the race in T TR TF were
selected based on their virulence on
commercially deployed surgeons and
ranges of seedling the distance from
single race to broad-spectrum were
observable in the panel and the field
resistance we observe it could be on
state resistance that means it's
qualitative or the presence of due to
the presence of adult plant resistance
this will see later after getting the
marker data indeed their analysis and
resistance can be boosted by combining
this is a certain ruler 46 with other
surgeons the next plan is to do us
analysis after getting the market data
and scoring of season or three India and
planting in phenotyping Ethiopia in
Kenya okay
as last hour like to thank my special
committee dr. mark Sorel's Gary Burton
dr. Gary person dr. Martinez and the ddw
of GW project of Cornell for funding dr.
Tony Coffman Kelly Archer and Linda
Martinez and my Institute AI R and the
DS arc pathology and breeding team
specially dr. paradigms
I should not even my troop are taking
care of my my nurseries in Ethiopia did
I get there and I'll also like to thank
dr. Karim amar from Siemens for
providing the marking population dr.
Bellin dr. up a a big dr. Bikel in dr.
al-abadi both for processing my imported
seeds and currently process here dr. mom
deep and route when era in Kenya for
phenotyping tinea the antenna dr. Pablo
libera from University of Minnesota we
did the seedling pollution together and
the USD in North Carolina for genotyping
dr. keen idea rate Kimberly dr. Brian
word and I would like to thank also my
lab mates Janek and my mark Soros in
Janet's lab group Daniel Sweeney dr.
Chantal Marty's le tag and dr. Adina
carcass
Travis Ronnie James Tanaka David painter
Amy folks
dr. John Luke Johnny dr. mom or somos
were shot Bakari and its origin thank
you all for listening if you have
questions I'd like to take something
[Applause]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu